early yesterday morning the
Congressional Appropriations committees
released their spending proposal
lawmakers will now have to read debate
and vote on the bill by Friday or the
government will shut down the bill is
4155 pages long
forget voting for a second forget
debating
how exactly is anyone supposed to read
4
155 pages in three days
The Iliad is roughly 700 pages
The Divine Comedy is about 800.
War and Peace
that 1225 pages
the Bible
roughly 1400 Pages if between now and
Friday
you somehow managed to read The Iliad
The Divine Comedy War and Peace and the
entire Bible
you would still not have read as many
pages as are contained in this spending
bill
now let's say you somehow managed it you
read all those books and you threw in
one extra book on top of that you threw
in speechless controlling words
controlling Minds Justin thank you very
much just to get you over the 4155 page
mark
do you think that you would be able to
organize your thoughts about those books
do you think that you would be able to
debate the major themes and plot points
raised by Homer Dante Tolstoy Moses Ezra
David Isaiah Matthew Mark Luke John Paul
Knowles and 31 or so other writers
in three days four days if you include
the day of the vote
at which point
you decide whether or not to spend 1.7
trillion dollars it's very difficult for
people to conceptualize what trillion is
that is 1.7 million million dollars
I strongly suspect
you would not be able to do that
I don't think any of us would I also
strongly suspect
you are much more intelligent than the
average congressman
but then that's the point the lawmakers
are never supposed to read these bills
they are just supposed to rubber stamp
them I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Renee tag who
says I have adult friends who don't have
their driver's license but have spent
thousands of dollars on their
squishmallow collection it's genuinely
very sad and concerning I'm
I'm just really happy that I can say I
have no idea what a swish a squish
mallow collection is
in my mind what I am picturing is a
mashup of Mitt Romney like Mitt Romney
wearing the Michelin Man suit like a big
marshmallow version of Mitt Romney and
the guys at the bulwark
you know and oh
all the libs
and the squishes and so that sounds kind
of cute and maybe I get that little
collection too but but it is very sad
when people are spending thousands of
dollars on toys and not behaving like
adults they should you should behave
like an adult okay you got to get big
and strong you gotta get a lot of iron
pumping through your veins you need to
check out good ranchers right now head
on over to goodranchers.com use code
Knowles a tough year on the economy
means that essential practical gifts
will be in high demand give the most
essential gift of all America's best
meat and seafood from good Ranchers with
discounts on orders of five boxes or
more you can save on gifts for the whole
family when you give a box of good
ranchers you are giving them a true
Steakhouse experience with 100 American
USDA prime and upper Choice cuts of beef
Chicken and Seafood other meat delivery
companies and even your local grocery
stores import lower Quality Meat from
overseas do not give your friends and
family less than America's very best
this year not all meat is created equal
not all meat delivery services are
created equal good ranchers offers you
the very very best right now go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s at checkout
to get 35 off your gift and then you
will get to eat like I eat when sweet
little Elisa Cooks up all that good
Ranchers go to goodranchors.com code
Knowles for 35 off good ranchers
American Meat delivered what is in this
Omnibus Bill
I don't know I didn't read the bill it
came out yesterday and it's over 4 000
pages long so I'm not going to sit here
and pretend like I read the build no one
has not one person on Earth has read
this entire bill
now what I can gather is in the bill
based on the small sections of the bill
that were proposed individually and the
people who sponsored them
and based on the reporting of the
handful of
trustworthy journalists that are left in
America
the the bill includes funding of the
government through September of next
year
it boosts defense spending by 76 billion
dollars to now total defense spending
will be 858 billion dollars brings
domestic spending uh it's got domestic
spending of 773 billion dollars then
we've got what we got 45 billion in
Military and economic aid for Ukraine
that's everyone's top priority right as
we just we we haven't given enough
billions and billions of dollars to
Ukraine Got to make sure top of the line
we give many many more billions this is
more money by the way than even Biden
requested Biden requested 37 billion
what they're going to end up going with
is 45. it includes five billion dollars
in earmarks for 3 200 projects I
actually don't care about that so much
that's just how laws are made laws are
made by saying okay Congressman can I
get your vote if I send a little bit of
money to your District hey all right
Congressman what if I I know you're
holding that firm well what if I build
this bridge in your District okay that's
fine and they got a really bad rap in
2008 John McCain made a big issue about
how terrible earmarks are but it was all
Bs John McCain only did that because he
was a huge big spending Republican on so
many other issues and earmarks account
for such an infinitesimally small
portion of federal spending that he said
okay I'm going to make a big example out
of earmarks and quote unquote pork
barrel spending meanwhile John McCain is
spending zillions of dollars on all
sorts of other nonsense that he wants so
I I I'm I don't mind you can have your
five billion it's a 1.7 trillion dollar
bill five billion dollars in basic
politics not as big a deal 47 billion
dollars for the National Institutes of
Health because they've been so
trustworthy and so effective in recent
years right what were would we do
without the NIH sending money overseas
to the Wuhan Institute of virality a
virology to fund gain a function
research what would we do oh goodness
what would we do if we weren't paying
the salary of Dr fauci why could you
imagine what would happen then we might
have a global pandemic or something so
good that we're spending 47 billion
dollars on the NIH a billion dollars for
Puerto Rico's electrical grid 600
million bucks to address water issues in
Jackson Mississippi
Josh Hawley is pushing to have a ban on
tick tock on government devices included
in the Omnibus so that's a good thing
right there are certain things in the
bill that are fine and they add in these
little good things uh as part of what is
broadly a terrible Bill and then this is
a tricky one they've included in the
spending Bill something called The
Electoral count Reform Act
and the Electoral count Reform Act is a
way to change the process for how
presidential elections are certified and
this is a terrible addition to the bill
but it's my favorite addition to the
bill
because it proves that conservatives
were right the whole time and we've been
being gaslit by democrats since election
day 2020. the Electoral count reform and
presidential transition Improvement Act
is a bill that was co-sponsored by Susan
Collins who's a liberal Republican
and Joe manchin who's a conservative
Democrat and so it's supposed to be this
bipartisan bill
and it amends our electoral count Act of
1887 so this is the biggest overhaul to
how presidential elections are conducted
from the federal level in a very long
time about a century and a half and what
it does is reaffirms that the vice
president has only a ministerial role at
the Joint session of Congress where the
Electoral College votes are counted so
remember last time January 6th there was
all this chatter about what the vice
president would do when the votes came
in
there were dueling slates of electors
some states didn't want to certify these
votes there was a big fight and why
because they changed the Democrats
changed all of the election rules right
before the election they used covet as
the excuse to do that but the way that
they changed the election rules gave a
huge advantage to Democrats and in some
cases like in the case of Pennsylvania
it violated the state constitution by
using things like widespread mail-in
ballots explicitly prohibited by the
state constitution so there was all this
question it wouldn't have been the first
time that this happened in the U.S in
the 1870s there were also many questions
about how the election was conducted and
as a result of that there was an
electoral commission that had been
appointed uh this this was the option
preferred by Senator Cruz in 2020 this
was the option preferred by
representative Paul gosar for instance
and a number of other Republicans in the
Congress it was all shot down everyone
knows then what happened the rest of the
day January 6th the worst day in the
history of the world well anyway this
electoral Reform Act that is being
wedged into the Omnibus because the
Democrats don't want to debate it on its
own merits this would amend that whole
process
and my favorite part of it is
it proves that the Democrats were lying
in 2020. in 2020 what the Democrats said
is
the the vice president
does not have the ability to reject
slates of electors the vice president
does not have the ability to send
electors back to the states to sort out
who the state actually voted for the the
vice president does not have the ability
not to certify the election that's what
we were told by all the Democrats and by
a lot of the libs on the Republican side
okay it's a complex historical political
legal question so what do I know maybe
they're except
if all that's true
then why do you need to pass this new
electoral account Reform Act
if that's so clearly true that the vice
president doesn't have any actual power
at the certification of presidential
elections
then why do you need to change the law
to take away his power to do anything at
the certification of presidential
elections
it's an admission that they were lying
or at least seriously overstating their
case in 2020 and so now what they're
trying to do is streamline the process
anymore such that if there are any
Shenanigans in the states there are
fewer ways for the people to come out
and object to them
not good stuff but it is something that
we can come to expect politicians who
are in power
want to stay in power
and the Democrats in particular who have
done a much better job at rigging
elections historically and certainly in
recent years than Republicans have done
do not want the people to have much
recourse
to questioning the results of those
elections
if for instance many more States adopt I
guess Most states at this point have
electronic voting processes and there
are some questions about that or some
questions about the widespread mail-in
ballots or some questions about ballot
harvesting or some questions about fraud
or some questions about
the precincts being shut down and people
not being allowed to count cast their
ballots in an orderly way and they have
to put them in a separate box called box
three like we just saw in Maricopa
County in 2022 then if this occurs
during a presidential election
there will be less recourse for the
people to object to that
that is what they want there is such
so there's so much in this Omnibus Bill
and what the Congress is betting on and
what the Democrats in particular are
betting on is that people don't want a
government shutdown
they're going to get everything through
in this bill it's going to probably be
the only legislation the Congress passes
for the next two years at this point
because we've got a split power we've
got a republican house coming in
Democrats still run the Senate Democrats
have the widest so they're not going to
actually do anything instead of passing
bills and debating them like instead of
just proposing the Electoral account
Reform Act and debating it and having
that be an open vote instead of just
debating more spending for Ukraine
instead of just debating more spending
for the NIH they're just going to throw
it all in there they're going to all
lump it in together and the the Congress
is going to
basically say they had no choice but to
vote for it and so we get more and more
and more spending on crazier things and
the American people
don't get to say boo about it what else
is in the bill this is this may be my
favorite part though I know I just said
that the Electoral account Reform Act is
my favorite part this one this one might
even beat that
the 1.7 trillion dollar Omnibus Bill
designates a part of Washington DC our
nation's capital is now going to be
designated as
Ukrainian Independence Park
and there are now going to be signs
around the park that include information
on the importance
of the independence freedom and
sovereignty of Ukraine
and the solidarity between the people of
Ukraine and the United States
I mean no offense to Ukraine I'm sure
Ukraine is a great place I'd love to
visit Kiev at some point I love the
chicken dish that comes from there
do
does anybody really believe that the
political status of Ukraine whether it's
a little bit more democratic which it
basically never has been or it's a
little more oligarchic which it pretty
much always has been and whether the
oligarchs lean more pro-russia which
they for a very long time have or if
they lean a little bit more pro-western
which they sometimes have that that does
anyone really believe that is a matter
of existential National importance to
the United States
does anybody believe that
no
no the only people who believe that
work on Capitol Hill not not one other
American really really believes that the
the bill is being sponsored by
representative Victoria Sparks who is
Ukrainian and she proposed the Ukrainian
Independence Park Act of 2022 and
representative Brian Fitzpatrick who is
one of the biggest squishies he's a
republican nominally but he's
effectively a Democrat huge squish uh
co-chair of the Congressional Ukraine
caucus and all of this got me thinking
we have a congressional Ukraine caucus
why do we have how many caucuses do we
have why do we have a congressional
Ukraine caucus I think my family is
Italian
okay I like
I like Italy
I like the Italian people this is no
knock on Italy the Italian people I
don't think we need to designate a part
of our nation's capital to being Italy
Square about the importance of Italy to
Amer I don't think Italy matters all
that much to America
Italy is a very important Place really
for the whole of Western civilization
and our history and how it developed but
the the political status of Italy at any
given point in time right now has
absolutely no bearing on the United
States and I don't think we need to
designate
part of our nation's capital to Italy
we can have a neighborhood we can have a
Little Italy and you go eat some Italian
food I don't think we need to have a
federal law that that sets aside part of
the nation's capital
for Italy or for Ukraine or for any of
this why do we have a Ukraine caucus why
is it that the American people pretty
much don't care about the political
status of most countries outside the
United States including Ukraine but on
Capitol Hill the Democrats are
completely head over heels for Ukraine
they all change their little you their
Twitter and Facebook bios to include the
Ukrainian flag for some reason absurd by
the way you're an American you should
have the American flag in your bio not
the not the flag of any other foreign
Nation no matter how sympathetic we
might be with that Nation but but a lot
of Republicans do though the whole
Republican establishment is Gaga over
Ukraine Mitch McConnell Senate majority
Senate minority leader leader of the
Republicans in the Senate has said that
the top priority for republicans
is Ukraine making sure the defense
department can deal with the major
threats coming from Russia and China
providing assistance for the ukrainians
to defeat the Russians
that's the number one priority for the
United States right now
according to most Republicans that's
sort of how we see the
challenges confronting the country at
the moment
that's the that's the top issue
according to Mr cocaine himself so what
does this show
what it shows is not just that those
guys on Capitol Hill are totally crazy
there are a lot of things but they're
not totally crazy they usually have a
reason for doing what they're doing they
are very rational actors politicians in
both parties inasmuch as they're very
very good at keeping themselves in power
they have a an uncanny ability for cold
calculation so what is the calculation
here on Ukraine
I think it shows you what a lot of
people have suspected from the beginning
which is that all this talk about the
independence and sovereignty of Ukraine
that's a bunch of nonsense Ukraine is a
border state a border Nation it has been
one for a long time it is a Battleground
for for fights between the East and the
West between Russia and Europe and the
United States and the reason that this
war broke out in the first place
is because in Ukraine 10 years ago you
had a pro-russian leader and the U.S
didn't like that very much and so
Western Powers put pressure on Ukraine
and helped to to fund and encourage
discontent in Ukraine that did already
exist to that that ultimately led to the
maidon Revolution and ousted the
pro-russian leader and put in a more Pro
wet pro-russian leader as did that guy
it's very confusing when you're talking
about Ukraine
the maidon revolution then led to a more
pro-western government in Ukraine then
you started seeing a lot of talk about
Ukraine joining the European Union
Ukraine joining NATO Russia said that
that would be an unacceptable security
risk to have NATO come that close to its
borders and that important the country
and so then you saw you saw Russia Annex
parts of Ukraine this is going back now
eight years and then you saw uh the
major war breakout earlier this year in
Ukraine and what this tells me is
Ukraine is not viewed as an independent
nation obviously by Russia or by the
United States and Europe Ukraine is
being viewed right now
as a theater of Empire
Russia says it openly
the U.S and the West
say it implicitly
when we say that Ukraine is the most
important issue for Americans what we're
saying is that the American Western
Empire is very important the American
World Order where we are the top dog and
we are we are governing the rules of the
world is very very important and I'm not
even disputing that that is the current
world order that we have and they're
saying we cannot allow Russia to
encroach on Ukraine why not because
Ukraine is this absolutely Sovereign
independent nation because
Ukraine is a part of the broader
Imperial project for
the US and the west and we all know that
to be the case I'm not even knocking it
I'm not attacking that I I'd rather we
run the world than the Russians run the
world or China run the world but that's
what it is it is an Imperial Battle we
like to think that we're living in the
new modern times we're so different from
all those terrible Old State actors in
the past remember when they fought Wars
of Empire and land Conquest we're doing
the exact same now because that's that's
a fact of politics that is just how
people interact in the world and that
that's what we're seeing that's what
that's what Mitch McConnell means when
he says it's the most important thing
it's the most important thing to what
the American Nation I don't think so I
think it's the most important thing to
the American Empire now Rand Paul would
disagree Rand Paul who is much more
interested in pulling back American
influence abroad and focusing in on the
problems that we've got here at home he
he asked the question where do the real
threats to America lie
I brought with me the Omni
4155 pages
when was it produced in the dead of the
night 1 30 in the morning when it was
released but what's the clamor the
clamor's devote vote now let's get it
done why are you standing in the way of
spending
well the real question is this what is
more dangerous are we at risk for being
invaded by a foreign power if we don't
put 45 billion into the military Are we
more at risk by adding to a 31 trillion
dollar debt
I think the greatest risk to our
national security is our debt the
American people don't want this they're
sick and tired of it they're paying for
it through the nose with inflation
adding a trillion dollars to the deficit
will simply fuel the fires that are
consuming our wages and consuming our
retirement plans it's a terrible system
someone needs to stand up we're standing
up and we're going to say no
preach pre-trend
what's amazing about rand's statement
here is that
he actually I believe got the number
wrong on military spending
he referred to the 45 billion dollar
number instead of the 76 billion dollar
number I think he confused the Boost to
American military spending with the
Boost to Ukraine spending and it's not a
knock on him one it's very confusing and
the reports are a little bit ambiguous
and it shows you the heart of the
problem which is that
the dams dropped this 4 000 plus page
Bill and they say okay you got to vote
on it in three days
where even a United States Senator
doesn't get a chance to vote on that and
when you look at the Boost of military
spending you had boosted military
spending for our country boost to
military spending for other countries
and they say without this without the 76
billion extra dollars that we get in
American military spending that country
is going to be an existential risk I
don't know I think Rand Paul is right I
think that our debt
poses a far larger long-term risk than
some marginal increase in defense
spending I remember 10 years ago Mitch
Daniels then the governor of Indiana a
lot of people thought he was going to
run for president he said we are facing
a new Red Menace this time it's not the
commies it's not the Soviets exactly
it's the debt it's a Red Menace
consisting of ink if we manage our own
country in such an irresponsible way
that we we become more and more
dependent on China to pay for all of our
Flights of Fancy and we open up our
borders and we allow domestic Discord to
tear our country apart then Russia is
going to be the least of our worries
guys we've got a lot more problems a lot
closer to home
very often when you want to improve your
position in the world it's best not just
to look out at everybody else but it's
it's good to look Inward and see how you
can improve yourself one great way to
take account of your spiritual life
would be to check out Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmitz right now go to
ascensionpress.com Knowles if you are
someone who has always wanted to read
and understand the Bible but you are not
sure where to start then check out the
Bible into your podcast from Ascension
the Bible linear podcast is currently
the most popular religion podcast in the
U.S millions of people have listened to
it twice it has hit the number one spot
on Apple podcasts
this is the only podcast that I reliably
Listen to In My Car
I work in podcasts so I don't I'm not
constantly consuming podcasts since I'm
in it every single day but Bible in a
year is the one I think I really have to
listen to that one it's hosted by father
Mike Schmitz he reads the entire Bible
in 365 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way if you miss a few days it's okay
sometimes it can become Bible in two
years if you want if in in my case I've
extended it a little longer it is
absolutely fabulous if you want to start
reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Knowles kwles to
download the reading plan for free that
is ascensionpress.com Knowles to
download the reading plan for free
speaking of threats
the people of the world and especially
Germany can rest easy tonight a 97 year
old woman
has been arrested and convicted of the
crime
that she was arrested for what is the
crime 97 year old woman
worked in a Nazi concentration camp
back when she was 18 years old
she was not firing guns
she was not giving orders
she was a secretary at a Nazi
concentration camp at stuttoff
and she was 18 years old now because of
her age
she was actually tried in juvenile court
a 97 year old woman
was tried in juvenile court
because she was a secretary at the age
of 18.
when her country was in a state of Total
War
she was given a two-year suspended jail
sentence
and she was found guilty of being an
accessory to the murder of ten thousand
five hundred and five prisoners and the
attempted murder of five other people
and this is where
when you just see the headline you say
this is really completely preposterous
but then when you see what she's found
guilty of
it makes it a little bit more morally
complex because
this woman was 18 years old working as a
secretary
for people who were doing very very bad
things
ten thousand plus people killed
with her participation in that I don't
know
part of me looks at that and says I
guess you should be held to account you
feel bad for a 97 year old woman you say
well those ten thousand five hundred
people they didn't get a chance to live
she got to live her whole life
then you say can a 97 year old woman
really be held responsible
for clerical work she did at the age of
18 when her country was in us that seems
unfair too that seems sort of unjust
what are we to make of this one you have
to ask yourself what is the point of
this at this point what is the point of
this prosecution
she wasn't a commander she wasn't giving
orders she wasn't carrying out orders
really she was just
writing things on paper she was just a
clerical functionary
what is the point of this the point of
this just to get one last ounce of
Justice or Revenge
what is the point to to show that if you
commit atrocities and War you'll be held
to account by The Victors even
80 years later
maybe maybe it is and maybe it's just
I'm not saying it isn't you know if my
Grandpa died or grandma died and
a concentration camp I'd probably want
that woman to actually serve time in
jail she was given a suspended sentence
I'd probably I don't care she's 97 I
probably wanted to go to jail I like to
think that I would be able to
have Grace and forgive her and say no
she should and she's 97 whatever but I
don't know I don't know what I would
feel I love my grandparents
but it does make you think
about us right now forget about World
War II for a second forget about the
Holocaust forget about this 97 year old
woman
just think about where we are right now
every year in the United States we kill
roughly 850 000 babies
since Roe v Wade was passed down from
the Supreme Court over 60 million
babies
have been killed in the United States
that's 10 times the number of Jews who
were killed in the Holocaust and that's
what that's five times the number
roughly of total victims of Hitler's
Terror
how many people will be held to account
for that
how many abortion doctors how many
people who handed down the law
furthermore how many secretaries are
there working right now at Planned
Parenthood today
who are signing off the death warrants
of all those little babies
and what's going to happen 80 years from
now I'm quite convinced that future
Generations will look back on our
generation with moral horror at what we
have done
850 000
people a year human beings living human
beings the most innocent people among us
snuffed out every year in their mother's
womb this is as horrific a crime as you
can possibly imagine and it's been going
on since 1973 and it will now contract a
little bit because of the Dobbs decision
there's a lot of people 60 million plus
people
how many people because what what this
woman will say and and what her
Defenders will say is well she wasn't
directly involved in the in the
atrocities she was indirectly involved
okay what about the people who are
indirectly involved in the atrocities
that we're seeing today people will look
back on abortion future Generations will
look back on it with the moral horror
that we look back on slavery that we
look back on genocides that we look back
on all of these things
and what will we say what about the 97
year old Secretary who worked at Planned
Parenthood decades from now
what will we say about her what should
we say about her I don't know I don't
have an easy answer on it I don't have
an easy answer on this 97 year old Nazi
secretary
from when she was 18.
but I do think that people ought to take
some stock of what they're doing right
now because
it's it's very easy to look back at the
past and see the horrors that happened
it's a lot harder to see it when you are
living through it and when you to more
direct or Less Direct degrees are
participating in it
a lot of people are going to look at
this they'll say doesn't Germany have
anything more important to do right now
than to go after a 97 year old woman
aren't there more pressing issues a lot
of people are looking right now at the
U.S Congress they're saying aren't there
more pressing issues than establishing
Ukraine independence Park in Washington
DC there are more pressing issues
here's a pressing issue
right now people are struggling
financially
because of Joe Biden's stupid policies
on energy and spending that have and
covid that have caused inflation to
Skyrocket
so spending power going through the roof
Energy prices going through the roof the
way that Joe Biden mismanaged the
Ukraine situation
Vladimir zielinski who reportedly might
speak at Capitol Hill today that remains
sort of unclear as we're as we're
recording the show right now
Vladimir zielinski said that had Joe
Biden not behaved as he had vis-a-vis
Russia that Russia would not have
invaded Ukraine
so the zelinski places blame for the
Ukraine war on Joe Biden
because Joe Biden lifted uh sanctions on
Putin's oil pipeline because because Joe
Biden said that if Putin only invaded in
a minor incursion that that wouldn't be
a huge deal so that's what we have and
because of that cost of everything going
through the roof people don't have a lot
of money
one way that you can make a lot of money
would be to not work in at least three
states maybe more
families of four I've got a daily wire
report on this right in my hands
families of four with neither parent
working can receive welfare benefits
worth in excess of six figures per year
in Washington Massachusetts and New
Jersey according to a study from the
committee to unleash prosperity
this this uh previous analysis from the
conservative think tank found that
federal Supplemental unemployment
benefits food stamp extensions child tax
credit payments and other benefits
offered in the aftermath of the
lockdowns and the whole covid regime
could exceed 120
000 in multiple States
and then even with the expiration of
that of those supplemental programs
because you might say okay well yeah the
government gave out a lot more money
during covid but then after covet it all
kind of went away right no there's a
recent study that found that
unemployment insurance and dramatic
recent expansion of Obamacare subsidies
can exceed the national median income in
24 States for families with two parents
and two children
and this analysis was not just done by
some random conservative think tank it
was completed by uchicago econ Professor
Casey Mulligan and Heritage Foundation
research fellow EJ and Tony
welfare benefits
can exceed the median national income
in roughly half the country
not a good set of incentives to have in
your country I am not one of these
Republicans who recoils at the very
thought of the government spending any
money to alleviate poverty or anything I
don't really that doesn't bother me I'm
as you know very well I'm not a
Libertarian I don't have any desire to
live in some Iran Atlas Shrugged future
where we're all just industrialists and
GDP is the most important thing in the
world I have no problem with the
government spending some money
to help the poor
but at a certain point
the free marketeers and the Libertarians
make a very good observation that when
the government creates perverse
incentives then it leads to people in
misery if the government creates
programs that will allow people to make
more money by not working than they
would by working that will be very very
bad not just for the country and with
regard to our terrible spending problem
and our massive debt that imperils
National Security and our whole American
future but it's bad for the people too
man was made to work by the sweat of our
brow shall we eat our food okay and so
when when people are put into these
welfare programs these social safety
nets can very quickly become spider webs
that just entrap you they get you stuck
in them and that leads to the breakdown
of family in many cases leads to the
breakdown of the human Spirit it
degrades us it degrades us individually
to grades our families it degrades our
whole society
while we're spending 1.7 trillion
dollars maybe we should take a look at
that and say we're going to help you if
you're poor
want to help you back get back on your
feet we're going to give you direct
payments as a matter of fact we're going
to subsidize you having more kids I'm
all for it we have a declining
population I want I want people to have
more kids but
we are not going to create a system in
which
you'll make more money if you don't work
that's not going to be good for anybody
speaking of families Amy Grant
who is apparently a Christian music star
I've never heard any of her songs but
she's apparently a Christian music star
she has announced that she's going to
host a lesbian wedding for her niece
she's drawn some
some controversy for this but she said
she's going to host this same-sex
wedding for her niece and she said look
Jesus told us there's two rules love God
above all else and love your neighbor
and so that's very simple to me I'm
gonna I want to love my neighbor and so
I'm gonna host my niece's same-sex
wedding and this is a total cop-out it's
taken completely out of context of the
gospels and it's not the right thing to
do
but it shows you
how difficult it can be to resist this
kind of stuff in our culture the reason
I bring up the story is not to scold Amy
Grant I don't know who Amy Grant is I
don't really care
but it's to show you how difficult it
can be how emotional manipulation can
really really screw up our politics
more on that in a second first that we
relaunched
or we recently launched for the first
time a brand new biblical series by Dr
Jordan B Peterson the series is called
Exodus and in it Jordan Peterson sits
down with other Scholars to read the
book of Exodus and discuss what it means
and why it remains significant thousands
of years after it was written Scholars
at the table include Dennis Prager
Jonathan pojo and many more the first
few episodes are available to stream
right now on daily wire Plus
there are more new episodes coming soon
trust me you've got to see this series
you must be a member to watch so head on
over to dailywire.com Knowles to become
a member and watch Exodus today
Amy Grant this apparently Christian
music star is going to host a lesbian
quote-unquote wedding for her niece
it's a hard case
it's a very hard case
but in doing it
in saying look I'm told to love my
neighbor and so I'm going to make an
exception here and I'm gonna host my
niece's gay wedding quote unquote even
if I disagree with it that's what I'm
going to do
that's not an example of a charitable
loving action and exception to one's
other
other sorts of views on things
it undermines the entire argument it
undermines the entire world view
the let what the left is saying is that
conservatives oppose gay marriage
because we hate gay people we can serve
it as we're just so hateful and we hate
gay people we never met a gay guy in our
lives I just want to throw them off of
buildings right that's what we want to
do
no no the reason that conservatives
oppose gay marriage is because we
recognize that marriage
necessarily intrinsically involves
sexual difference and if you remove
sexual difference which is at the heart
of marriage then you haven't opened up
marriage to include more people you have
just destroyed the entire concept of
marriage if marriage does not include
sexual difference it cannot mean
anything at all and so it is not a
loving or charitable Act
to our gay friends who every
conservative has gay friends every
single one
it's not it's not that we hate our gay
friends
it's not with they're our friends we
love our friends
it's that it is not
possible it if you say look I oppose gay
marriage quote unquote gay marriage and
I think marriage has this meaning but
I'm going to make this one exception to
host my niece's lesbian wedding
then you've just gutted your whole
argument it all that tells it tells
people is that you don't actually
believe what you said you believed what
that suggests is actually that the libs
were right that your opposition to quote
unquote gay marriage is that you
actually do hate lesbians or gay people
but you like your knees and so okay I'm
gonna make an exception here it's the
same thing with abortion the the
manipulation that you see from the libs
on abortion is this they say oh you're
pro-life
yes yeah you oppose abortion
yes yeah why do you oppose abortion
obvious I think a person's a person no
matter how small and and if we're gonna
have any rights at all the right to life
has to be the most important one because
without the right to life none of the
other rights can possibly exist and and
I think
human beings are made in the image and
likeness of God and we don't have a
right to Snuff them out in the womb or
murder them that would be wrong
yeah well what about in the case of rape
this is always this is the hard case
this it's an a very very small
percentage of abortions far less than
one percent of abortions every year but
they always use that manipulation they
always use that hard case to say what
about in the case of rape and a lot of
not pro-lifers but a lot of
conservatives or people who haven't
really thought through the issue they
might say
yeah okay that's fine you can get an
abortion in the case of rape
they view this as a loving reasonable
conciliation but it's not reasonable at
all it undermines the whole argument
if you believe all the stuff that you
just said that you believe
then you you can't Grant in principle an
exception to rape I guess as a practical
or Prudential matter if you were given a
bill that said we're going to get rid of
99 of abortions but we're going to leave
this one exception for rape then as a
Prudential matter you might say okay I'm
going to reduce the number of abortions
by 99 right now but you're you can't
Grant it in principle you can't say in
principle that
it's okay to kill a baby if the baby was
conceived through rape because because
then what that implies is the reason you
opposed abortion
actually is that you just didn't like
women or something like that what that
implies is that the libs were actually
right about your motivations and that
you didn't actually believe that a
person's a person no matter how small
and that man has made in the image and
likeness of God and that we don't have
the right to murder people even if
they're conceived in inconvenient
circumstances
even if they're conceived in a crime in
a heinous crime
you don't actually believe that that's
that's how they get you and so you've
got to stand you've got to think through
these things
and because if if you if you don't stand
firm on those difficult cases
you will you will have gutted the entire
argument that's why the libs focus on
those hard cases that's why they try try
to emotionally manipulate you on all of
them
speaking of
LGBT issues
it was a great interview from the series
creator of Dahmer this would be Ryan
Murphy and I started watching Dahmer I
thought it was a good show sweet little
Elisa couldn't get that into it you know
it's a little grisly
I won't spoil the story but Jeffrey
Dahmer had a not very pleasant life
difficult to watch it I think girls in
particular you know get a little
squeamish with it so
Ryan Murphy
I came under Fire because the Dahmer
series was listed as as an lgbtq Series
so they have all these tags on Netflix
and the various streaming platforms they
say this is horror or this is a rom-com
or this is an LGBT show and so with with
Jeffrey Dahmer who's one of the most
notorious serial killers in psychosexual
sadists in human history it listed it as
LGBT because he was a gay guy and he
only attacked guys and and mostly black
guys specifically I don't think it was
listed as an African-American piece of
entertainment but it was listed as LGBT
and there was an uproar because they
said oh how dare you lump in Jeffrey
Dahmer with LGBT
sexual identity has everything to do
with everything
unless the guy does something bad and
then it has nothing to do with it at all
so Ryan Murphy dismissed this criticism
he said my job as an artist is to hold
up a mirror about what happened
it's ugly it's not pretty do you want to
look at it if you do watch it if you
don't look away and sometimes some of
this outrage is directed at the frame of
the mirror instead of the reflection wow
hardcore stuff
does this mean that Ryan Murphy is a
homophobe he just set out to smear gay
guys and well no because
Ryan Murphy is a gay guy he says I think
that it got the LGBT tag one because of
my involvement I'm a gay man so most of
my stories deal with some sort of lgbtq
thing and I do that selfishly when I was
growing up I had nothing to look to
my mission statement has been to talk
about those stories and those characters
in Unearthed varied history
she was saying yeah it's probably just
because of me because I'm a gay guy and
sometimes if there's an LGBT director
then they'll put the tag too he says and
I I am selfish as an artist in that I am
interested in the LGBT idea and so I
tell stories about that and I don't only
tell really pretty stories where it's
all Will and Grace you know everything
about LGBT is always wonderful and fun
and gay I mean even the word gay became
a euphemism for LGBT because gay used to
mean happy and now gay is almost never
used in that sense like the song you
know I feel pretty it was so pretty I
feel pretty and witty and gay
which I I am certain is about to be
clipped out for a meme and that's fine I
don't care that's all right
used to mean that now all it means is
LGBT
well what he's saying is no there's bad
stuff that happens all throughout the
world there's no group of people
that is immune from bad stuff and bad
characteristics
but that is contrary to what the culture
says in our culture all gay things have
to be perfectly good
all traditional things have to be
perfectly bad
if they make a show or a movie about
Africa
specifically about black Africa I guess
they could they could make a negative
movie or show about
white colonization of Africa and they've
made a lot of those but about Africa and
Africans and traditional African
societies it always has to be wonderful
if they make a movie about
the Americas before the arrival of the
Europeans it always has to be wonderful
America before the evil white man got
here it was all just this Pocahontas
have you ever seen the colors of the
rainbow in the then the Europeans get
there and they ruin everything the only
guy who can make a movie suggesting
that indigenous societies maybe weren't
all gumdrops and Roses would be Mel
Gibson that movie would be Apocalypto
it's a much more realistic view of
things but in our culture
we have decided certain groups and
certain ideas and certain societies
can only be good
those happen to be
non-western societies
you see this breakdown everywhere gay
good straight bad
woman good man bad
every race of people on Earth good white
people bad
East
the Far East the middle east Southeast
Africa good the West bad
and and when you transgress those lines
in either direction if you suggest that
maybe maybe indigenous Society or maybe
LGBT culture or maybe any of these
things might have some problems with it
you will be written off and if you
suggest that the Europeans ever did
anything good that maybe Christianity
has something to recommend it you you
will you will also falleth out of that
culture as well that's just the rule has
nothing to do with reality has nothing
to do with holding up a mirror in in
fact in some cases
it's probably because people do not like
what they see in the mirror they don't
like what they see in themselves and so
there always have to be other Pro every
bad thing that befalls anybody has to be
somebody else's fault you can never take
a look at the man in the mirror
now much like
the former president I have a major
announcement okay
yes or no the game is back and available
for pre-order over at dailywire.com shop
we have this hit game show on YouTube
and the hit game show
is called yes or no and it's the show
where I sit down with my friends and we
drink and we you know respond to prompts
and we try to figure out how well we
know the other person the show really
took off we we put it up in the store I
think we ordered a thousand or so games
sold out instantly and I'm really
frustrated because a lot of people have
tried to order it before Christmas and
it just it sold out way too fast so we
are re restocking right now you can
pre-order yes or no brings the fun home
and puts your knowledge of your friends
and family to the test play with up to
nine people and discuss the most
pressing issues of our time including
the likelihood of alien existence
questions about God life and the
universe and so much more you may have
missed out on helping to make this the
stocking stuffer of the year since it
sold out so quickly but now is your
chance to secure your copy of the best
selling game pre-order yes or no at
dailywire.com shop we've also got
a magician coming up on the member block
right now a magician who pulled off one
of the most impressive magic tricks of
the year go check it out if you're not a
member
you got to join click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]